-Guys, do you ever see a photo
in the news
and think the headline
could be much better?
I'm going to show you
what I mean.
It's time for "News and
Improved." Here we go.
-♪ News and Improved ♪
-For example, check out this
first photo.
The original headline was...
Headline could definitely be
improved, because if you only
looked at the photo,
the headline could have been...
[ Applause ]
Let's check out
this next photo here.
The original headline was...
If you only looked at the photo
the headline could have been...
[Slurring] "I just
happened to notice that."
Up next, this headline says...
Headline could have been...
It's like, "So, you cover your
whole -- half of your face."
This next headline was...
But the headline
could have been...
[ Applause ]
This next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Applause ]
This next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Steve squeaks ]
Next headline was...
But the headline
could have been...
They should do that.
-Yeah.
♪♪
Put a ring on it.
-The next headline was...
Headline could have been...
An actual goat.
Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
-Yeah. Look good. Yeah.
-And, finally,
this headline was...
But the headline
could have been...
That's all the time we have
for "News and Improved."